you all know I talk about critical
thinking all the time it's more
important I would argue than ever and
we're not teaching kids to develop these
skills they don't know how to think
through a problem make informed
decisions think independently and that
is exactly what the right wants because
they know when kids learn to do those
things they certainly don't end up
voting for Republicans I have a book in
front of me that I wrote which is now
available we've not done anything like
this before and by the way it's a hell
of a lot more work than I thought the
book is called think like a detective
it's a kid's book for critical thinking
davidpackman.com book it's on Amazon as
a Kindle book it's on Amazon as a
paperback when you gift this book you're
empowering kids to think critically and
that is exactly what we want to do the
more critically they think the better
the choices they will make when it comes
to voting for our elected officials and
the better off we are all going to be